well this is not a scam eight news now
is partnering with Smith's to collect
food for homeless teens here in southern
Nevada you can pick up some items while
you're doing your own shopping to help
feed our homeless teens during our great
food drive Heather Mills Candace Charles
both out live this morning from The
Smiths on East Lake Mead and Warm
Springs Road in Henderson but to tell us
more about it and to tell us how we can
help you guys are filling up those boxes
good for you girls what's going on
it is so awesome Sherry to be out here
with Candace and with project 150 but
the thing is that we know our community
is generous but there is a timeline on
this we only have until Friday so we
want you to come out in Hoards today
absolutely look at the work that people
have already done yes bring in a little
bit of everything for project 150 and
have some little here for me for project
150 tell me a little bit about how this
is going to help you guys I know you
guys just had Thanksgiving your pantry
needs to be filled tell us about your
work yeah so we just provided over 2 000
holiday meals which has the turkey as
well as all the sides including the
non-perishable Goods so this will help
us replenish our pantry to be able to
provide those family meal bags which
goes out to over 1400 students on a
monthly basis so please come out donate
to any of the Smiths around the location
awesome really quickly tell me what
exactly you guys are looking for yes so
we're looking for non-perishable Goods
specifically uh breakfast lunch dinner
snacks anything to help the students and
their families go about their days and
or weekends and so cereal we've seen
beans we've seen all the good
non-perishables that can help our
families feed their feed their tummies
so yeah awesome thank you so much thank
you for the work that you're doing for
our community it really is appreciated
as you can see so many different places
but you know what you guys this is just
a little bit of what they have the
Smiths here a lake mean Henderson
Henderson is out in full force they've
been working look at this here guys they
have a little bit of everything pita
bread that's awesome listen you guys
still have time though to help us fill
up even more all the way till Friday
right out there I want to see at least
like six 12 cars today we can do it it's
open get in here
otherwise of course we'll have some
other folks later on as well you guys
can check out all the details on our
website newsnow.com